là
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat pour suivre
et bien une audition consacrée au budget
rectificatif ce nouveau plan d'urgence
qui a été annoncée aujourd'hui deuxième
plan d'urgence depuis le début de la
crise du coronavirus je vous rappelle
que l'on est passé d'une somme de 45
milliards d'euros pour ce plan d'urgence
à trois semaines plus tard 110 milliards
d'euros annoncées à l'issue du conseil
des ministres tout à l'heure les
sénateurs de la commission des finances
font donc une audition pour en savoir
plus sur ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative en présence de gérald
darmanin le ministre des comptes publics
ainsi que les secrétaires d'état agnès
pannier runes haché et olivier du soft
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
était annoncé dans un premier temps mais
il est finalement excusé notez que ce
budget donc est passé de 45 à 110
milliards d'euros en trois semaines dont
8 milliards d'euros pour notre système
de santé notamment pour le matériel mais
aussi pour les soignants noter aussi les
prévisions macroéconomiques avec un
déficit d'environ 9% une croissance en
baisse de 8% et enfin une dette de 115%
en plus de ce plan d'urgence le
gouvernement a tout à l'heure également
précisé les primes qui ont été annoncées
pour les fonctionnaires fonction de pour
fiona publique d'état fonction publique
hospitalière fonction publique
territoriale ainsi que tout un système
d' aide pour les plus démunis
écoutez d'ailleurs julien de normandie
qui est revenu tout à l'heure sur le
sujet lors de la séance de questions de
contrôle au gouvernement nous avons
annoncé aujourd'hui une aide
exceptionnelle une aide d'urgence
sociale à destination de toutes les
personnes au rsa à la ss pour 150 euros
pour ces couples mais également à
hauteur de 100 euros par enfant
pour ces personnes au rsa et à la ss
mais également à hauteur de 100 euros
par enfant pour toutes les personnes aux
apl au moment où je vous parle
ces quatre millions de foyers
1 4 million de foyers qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de cette aide exceptionnelle
à compter du 15 mai avec une grande
rapidité et sans aucune démarche à faire
je crois que là aussi c'est un témoin de
cette solidarité qui n'est nécessaire la
réponse encore une fois elle et
sanitaires économiques mais aussi
sociales voilà donc cette mesure de
justice sociale qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement en début d'après-midi une
aide de 150 euros qui devrait avoir lieu
le 15 mai 100 euros supplémentaires sont
prévus par enfant pour plus de 4
millions de foyers
voilà ce qui a été nous annoncer tout à
l'heure par le gouvernement est précisé
par julien de normandie pendant la
séance de questions de contrôle en plus
de cela notez bien tout un système de
primes qui a également été annoncée par
le gouvernement prime exempte de tout
prélèvement de toute charge prime
entièrement défiscaliser 1500 euros pour
les soignants qui soigne dans les
hôpitaux qui ont eu des malades du col
vide de 19 500 euros pour les autres
soignante également une revalorisation
des heures supplémentaires valorisés à
hauteur de + 50 %
notez enfin que et bien le gouvernement
veut également une prime 1 pour les
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
territoriale notamment et bien pour ceux
qui travaillent dans les ehpad et le
monde médico-social nous devons échanger
là dessus avec les départements à
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure précisé le
gouvernement pour ce qui concerne bien
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative dont il va être question
cet après midi avec agnès pannier
relâchés gérald harman a ainsi
qu'olivier du soft en présence du
président de la commission des finances
le socialiste vincent eblé noter que par
ailleurs et bien l'ensemble de cette
audition aura lieu en visioconférence a
notamment pourrait bien le rapporteur
général de la commission albéric de
montgolfier noter que et bien sûr ce
sujet il devrait y avoir réellement aux
débats
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative le premier plan d'urgence
avait été adopté conforme
ici au sénat mais cette fois ci est bien
les sénateurs souhaitent avoir un
véritable débat en effet la gauche
appelle à une plus grande contribution
des grandes fortunes sur ce sujet tandis
que la droite appelle l a transformé les
reports de charges en annulation elle
juge également les fonds le fonds de
solidarité qui a été mise en place
toujours insuffisant a lieu également
que les travailleurs indépendants ne
sont pas suffisamment aidé voilà cette
audition est en train de commencer il y
à là dans la salle je vous le précise au
sénat vincent eblé le président
socialiste de la commission des finances
en présence des ministres voilà il vient
de régler son système de visioconférence
on prend tout de suite donc la direction
de cette audition salué en votre nom
madame et messieurs les ministres
nous avons appris dans l'après midi que
le ministre
le maire serait remplacé par madame la
secrétaire d'état
tanière une hache et que nous
remerciant de sa présence est évidemment
confirmation de la présence du ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics
gérald darmanin et du secrétaire d'état
olivier dussopt chacun dans leur domaine
ils nous apporteront des éclairages sur
en particulier c'est l'objet de notre
réunion le deuxième projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2020 un
programme de stabilité est limitée à
l'année 2020 nous a également été
transmis en vertu de l'article 14 de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques 2011 2014 qui prévoit que le
gouvernement adresse au parlement au
moins deux semaines avant sa
transmission à la commission européenne
le projet de programme de stabilité
un mois après le déclenchement des
mesures de confinement nous nous
réunissons selon des modalités
particulières celles de la
visioconférence dans cette salle monory
nous avons déjà procédé
je le dis pour nos interlocuteurs
ministérielle de la sorte depuis une
quinzaine de jours d'abord pour des
échanges de vues entre membres de la
commission puis pour entendre un panel
d'économistes sur les réponses à
apporter face à la déstabilisation de
notre économie par la crise sanitaire et
ce matin même pour auditionner le
gouverneur de la banque de france
françois vilotte galop et le médiateur
du crédit médiateur national du crédit
entre 30 et 40 de nos collègues étaient
présents à chacune de ses réunions ce
qui est un chiffre tout à fait
satisfaisant sur la base de nos quarante
neuf membres et je veux les en remercier
collectivement et individuellement pour
ceux qui sont présents en cette fin
d'après midi
nous publions par ailleurs régulièrement
avec le rapporteur général albéric de
montgolfier une note de conjoncture une
note de suivi des
mesures prises dans le cadre du premier
plfr et de la loi d'urgence dans le
domaine financier bien entendu nous
sommes à la troisième édition de cette
note qui s'actualise donc de façon
régulière et qui est communiqué aux
membres de la commission et ensuite par
rebond au travers des groupes à
l'ensemble des membres de la haute
assemblée est également je crois
diffusées à l'extérieur pour ceux qui
veulent suivre en détail nos travaux
nous poursuivrons nos travaux dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent
après l'examen du plfr par exemple pour
entendre la dg philippe labbé pays
la fédération bancaire française parce
que nous avons dans notre programme de
travail également les représentants des
assurances
tout cela sous forme de visioconférence
qui est une modalité qui est bien adapté
pour des auditions et des échanges de
points de vue et des analyses
elle l'est moins pour les réunions à
proprement législatives avec
délibération et vote est là en fait nous
allons articuler une solution de
présentiel physique et léger pour
respecter les mesures giret et les
gestes barrières les mesures de
distanciation mais nou lé
l'associé de la visioconférence pour
ceux de nos collègues qui eux
resteront en province à cet égard madame
et messieurs les mini jeux vous rappelle
que nous avons besoin de l'entière
disponibilité de vos services si je puis
dire pour nous donner au fur et à mesure
les éléments d'information nécessaires à
notre travail de contrôle et je les
remercie de leur mobilisation en cette
période difficile nous avons bien reçu
les services du premier ministre une
première réponse à un courrier nous lui
avions adressé pour avoir quelques
éléments chiffrés pour en venir au
deuxième projet de loi de finances
rectificative
il acte comme notre note du 3 avril
dernier l'anticiper malheureusement une
détérioration que je qualifierais de
sévère de la situation économique de
notre pays et par voie de conséquence de
nos finances publiques avec des chiffres
jamais vu en termes de récession mais
rouen 8% de déficit
- 9 % du pib et de dette qui
s'établirait désormais à 115% du pib
ce plfr de procède également à un
certain nombre d'ajustements sur les
dispositifs qui avaient été ouverts dans
le premier pfr notamment le fonds de
solidarité et les garanties d'emprunt
accordés aux entreprises
il crée enfin un nouveau programme
budgétaire de 20 milliards d'euros pour
alimenter les participations financières
de l'état
je ne doute pas que les questions de mes
collègues de la commission des finances
seront nombreuses sur les sujets du
soutien aux entreprises en difficulté de
même que sur la situation des finances
publiques et/ou des finances locales ou
encore sur les mesures prévues pour les
ménages et notamment les plus modestes
d'entre eux
je rappelle évidemment à chacun qu'il
soit en ligne ou qu'ils souhaitent ici
physiquement présent que notre audition
est à la fois enregistré diffusé en
direct sur le site internet du sénat
donc il est nécessaire que tous les
micros soient bien éteints sauf quand
vous demandez et prenez la parole quand
je
la corde enfin si certains de mes
collègues en visioconférence entre un
souci micro ils peuvent utiliser le chat
pour transmettre leurs questions je vous
cède maintenant sans plus tarder la
parole pour un bref propos introductif
je ne sais pas dans quel ordre
gérald gérald darmanin pour débuter ne
vous écoutez monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances merci monsieur le
rapporteur général dames et messieurs
les sénateurs
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
faire un bref tour pour introductif
lorsque le plus intéressant évidemment
c'est de répondre à vos questions
le plfr deux vient modifier le budget de
l'état comme vous le savez il vient
d'abord recharger si j'ose dire des
crédits décidé et adopté y compris par
votre chambre je vous en remercie au nom
du gouvernement du plfr un îlien créer
de nouveaux droits
singulièrement des droits économiques là
serait un état sans doute développera
mais aussi d'autres droits notamment les
annonces autour de prime de précarité
c'était évoqué ce matin par le premier
ministre notamment il vient aussi
modifier un certain nombre de
dispositions de l'être pour pouvoir
armer encore plus de pays face à la
crise il vient remettre à jour un
certain nombre de précisions
macroéconomique que vous avez cité
monsieur le président et il prévoit
également des enseignements sur la suite
des événements mais je voudrais ici
sweeney monsieur le président que ce
plan est un plan d'urgence est pas un
plan de relance
viendra le moment où il y aura de la
relance sans doute des modifications
budgétaires
par ailleurs il ne s'agit pas non plus
de prévoir des crédits santé ou des
crédits qui sont ceux qui relèvent du
champ social non étatique puisque vous
le savez bien le plfss
r
c'est à dire la modification du budget
de la sécurité sociale n'est pas une
obligation juridique et budget d'état y
en ait créé limitatif doit passer par le
parlement évidemment l autorisation
parlementaire
le budget de la sécurité sociale est
indicatif c'est donc pour cela qu'il n'y
a pas de crédit requis relève de la
santé alors que nous en dépensons bien
évidemment en ce moment pour à peu près
8 milliards d'euros
et j'ai répondu je répondrai à la
convocation de la commission des
affaires sociales de votre assemblée la
semaine prochaine pour indiquer les
montants effectivement de dépenses et
déficits
ce plfr donc vient modifier les grandes
actions du gouvernement
110 milliards d'euros tout le mulet
d'action au public
ça nous fait effectivement 9 % de
déficit de déficit est désormais à 185 8
5 milliards d'euros s'avère qu'il a
doublé en 3 mois puisqu'ils étaient à
peu près avec l'autre à 11 milliards
d'euros dans le budget initial que par
ailleurs nous sommes à 61 % de dépenses
dans le pipe dépenses publiques
évidemment de ce corps si j'ose dire
extrêmement impressionnant nous sommes à
115% de dettes et peut-être que des
ministres on parlera également mais une
croissance qui est autour évidemment de
celle prévue par la banque de france
notamment autour de 8% bluetooth et -8%
bien sûr mais ces chiffres sont
évidemment très indicatif ils vont
évoluer avec la l'actualité économique
et actualités autour du confinement ou
de l'état sanitaire donc le plfr vient
nourrir d'abord les crédits décidé en
première partie on peut les faire un
d'abord recharger ses j'ose dire
l'argent que l'on met dans le chômage
partiel qui connaît un succès je le mets
encore une fois des guillemets très
important puisque aujourd'hui un salarié
sur trois et thomas chômage partiel dans
notre pays
l'état se substitue donc aux employeurs
et ses 24 milliards d'euros désormais y
compris avec l'argent de l'unedic qui
sont concernées concept qui vont vers le
chômage partiel
le fonds des indépendants le fonds
d'indemnisation ces 7 milliards d'euros
désormais me voilà place du milliard
évoqué peut-être que j'aurai l'occasion
de répondre à des questions sur ce point
avec la ministre mais
l'état a déjà émis 750 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui les assureurs ont versé 185
millions d'euros sur les 200 millions
d'euros prévus les régions n'ont pas
encore versé l'argent sur le compte de
l'état et du fonds mais la région
bretagne et la région de 7 à nyon fait
savoir aujourd'hui à la direction
générale des finances publiques leurs
futurs versements mais c'est à peu près
6 milliards de crédits en plus que mais
l'état pour pouvoir répondre aux
diverses améliorations de ce fonds créé
demandé 900 plus de 900000 indépendant
et 684 millions ont déjà été dépensés
peut-être la ministre reviendra sur les
améliorations apportées par le fonds est
notamment demandé par nombreux
parlementaires évidemment des sénateurs
en premier lieu troisième homme il vient
aussi mettre de côté si j'ose dire les
taxes que payent les compagnies
aériennes dans le budget annexe 10e
basse et à gérer les contrôleurs aériens
sont pris un décret avec mu et
l'économie des finances et miser
transport pour par reporter ce paiement
d'impôts et de charges pour ce pour ce
conte annexes mais il vient aussi ce
dispositif du plfr deux très nouveau
droit à rien des droits qui relève
stricto sensu de l'intervention
économique et missa d'économies qu'il
s'agisse de 20 milliards en argent
nous mettrons d'un budget annexe de la
pe la ministre en parlera j'imagine
également du fonds d'intervention qui
passe de 75 milliard un milliard d'ot
qu'on appelle le fds pour les
entreprises et puis il ya des
dispositions qui relève proprement des
interventions budgétaires notamment une
proposition tout à fait innovantes ont
surpris la commission des finances
puisque nous avons mis deux milliards et
demi de ce que nous pourrions appeler
des dépenses accidentelle prévu
explicitement par article 7 de la lolf
qui n'a jamais utilité utilisé jusqu'à
présent est le nom que le conseil d'état
a bien voulu autoriser malgré le fait
que nous n'ayons pas contrairement à
toutes les traditions si j'ose dire
parlementaire mais expressément prévues
par la loi organique de d'affectation de
ces crédits je peux d'ores et déjà dire
que cette poche de dépenses accidentelle
et imprévisible que chacun peut
comprendre sera en partie déjà utilisé
dans le débat puisque c'est là dedans
que nous prendrons les 880 millions
d'euros
le rapporteur général de l'assemblée
nationale et aura sans doute a déposé un
amendement pour les maîtres auprès du
ministère de la santé des solidarités
pour paraître le versement des primes
précarité
pour les publics les plus sensibles et 4
millions de personnes concernées avancer
ce matin par le premier ministre et
comme nous faisons le budget c'est juste
dire un peu tous les jours en
construction en marchant je voulais déjà
vous de vous le signifier nous
continuons évidemment les reports de
charges vous avez vu que présente la
réplique a annoncé des annulations que
j'ai expliciter ce matin dans la presse
et puis tout à fait prêts à continuer à
faire devant vous des reports évidemment
de paiement d'impôts s'il le faut
notamment son impôt sur les sociétés et
sur les taxes et les dispositions du
plfr 2 prévoit également des
dispositions pour les gouvernement de
nouvelle calédonie 240 millions d'euros
de prêt de l'afd la polynésie française
n'est pas encore prête dans sa demande
elle nous a fait sa demande hier soir
j'ai le président fritsch au téléphone
sans doute que dans une prochaine
exposition nous aurons à prêter de
l'argent à la polynésie et puis grâce à
une disposition qui permet d'améliorer
le travail économique et social du pays
notamment des dispositions de
défiscalisation des primes pour la
fonction publique décidée et peut être
que le secret d'état on parlera aussi
évidemment pour parler de ces primes
qu'elles relèvent de l'état des
collectivités locales puisqu'on a prévu
effectivement l'instrument ou de la
fonction publique hospitalière
nous n'avons pas prévu dans le plf r22
dispositions relatives aux collectivités
locales à l'exception des choses qui
nous permettent de mieux avancer parce
que pas prévu dans lordonnance de madame
gouro et de monsieur le corps nu
notamment sur les syndicats qui peut pas
faire des avances de trésorerie
il n'aurait pas été possible pour de
reporter comme on l'a fait pour les
ordonnances pour les collectivités
locales leur vote du budget en juillet
prochain donc ce sont des choses
exceptionnelles mais qui peuvent aider
les territoires à mieux vivre
il y aura évidemment des dispositions
autour des collectivités locales sans
doute dans un prochain texte financier
qu'on vous proposera elles ne sont pas
dans l'urgence absolue partager
aujourd'hui d'abord parce que beaucoup
de collectivités locales si elles vont
avoir des pertes de recettes
je pense aux droits de mutation je pense
évidemment aux octroi de mer pour
l'autre mère je pense à la tva pour les
régions par exemple souvent ces
paiements sont en décalage de mois voire
d'années c'est qu'à la tva pour les
régions et donc nous avons un petit peu
de temps parce qu'il est très difficile
de savoir exactement comment les choses
se passeront en attendant la direction
générale
finances publiques comme le direction
générale des collectivités locales
permettra s'il le faut de faire des
avances de trésorerie bien sûr pour
pouvoir répondre aux questions que se
poseront les collectivités locales je
sais que votre assemblée
particulièrement attentif il y sera
associée si vous le souhaitez monsieur
le président et nous verrons
effectivement un certain nombre de
dépenses qui relève vraiment de chant
très différents sont les types de
collectivités
on aura l'occasion sans doute d'en
reparler voilà monsieur le président en
quelques mots très très rapide je vais
peut-être si vous souhaitez c'est la
parole à madame la ministre pour qu'elle
expose en excusant monsieur mise
l'économie des finances autres dans le
g20
les mesures économiques de bercy et
monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès de
moi pour utilement compléter les
questions de fonction publique
merci beaucoup monsieur le président de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
vous l'avez compris l'objectif de ce
nouvel ce nouveau pelé ferrer c'est de
limiter au maximum la casse de notre
outil de production et de notre capital
humain
c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement vous présente ce projet de
loi ce projet de loi repose sur une
prévision de dégradation de la
croissance de 8% de 8 points pour 2020
ce n'est qu'une prévision c'est ce que
monsieur le ministre vient d'indiquer
qu'il faut considérer avec prudence
compte tenu de l'incertitude économique
elle est fondée sur la durée de
confinement annoncée par le président la
république et des hypothèses
deux sorties de confinement avec un
rebond économique progressif une montée
en puissance progressive et également
des hypothèses sur la situation de nos
principaux partenaires on considère que
l'europe va être linéaire comme nous et
les situeront on prend en compte des
situations particulières de rebond en
chine de difficultés aux etats-unis et 2
peut-être meilleure tenue au japon mais
tout cela est de soumis à l'examen des
faits et à la façon dont l'épidémie va
se poursuivre et assassinent éthiques ce
projet de loi de finances
il complète le plan d'urgence que nous
avions déjà mis en place je rage en
rappel les trois axes la kz2
préservation de l'emploi et des
compétences autour du chômage partiel
qui profondément renforcer en termes de
crédit à hauteur de 24 milliards d'euros
monsieur ministre vient d'indiquer le
deuxième axe et le soutien à la
trésorerie des entreprises sur cet axe
là avec la mise en place d'une garantie
de l'état à hauteur de 300 milliards
d'euros
une garantie des assureurs crédit à
hauteur de dix milliards d'euros et une
garantie des assureurs export à hauteur
de 2 milliards d'euros ça c'est ce que
vous aviez voté et sur cet angle là les
approfondissements se sont fait en
tenant compte d'un certain nombre de
deux points qui a été re remonter
notamment dans l'examen du premier palet
ferrer sur la question de l'accès ou du
traitement des entreprises en difficulté
je vais revenir et ils ont également été
traitées dans les négociations que nous
avons de manière quasi quotidienne avec
les banques de façon à obtenir des
interventions beaucoup plus automatiques
et des traitements beaucoup plus
homogène par catégories d'entreprises et
je suis disponible pour répondre à vos
questions sur ces sujets là enfin le
troisième axe c'est le soutien aux
indépendants au travers du fonds de
solidarité qui s'adresse à toutes les
tpe artisans commerçants micro
entrepreneurs professions libérales
réalisant moins de 1 million de chiffre
d'affaires et qui ont soit été fermée
par décision administrative soit ont
subi une perte de chiffre d'affaires de
plus de 50 % entre mars 2009 et mars
2020 aujourd'hui plus de 900 mille
entreprises ont fait appel à ce fonds
depuis sa création 900 mille entreprises
qui ont donc 1500 euros sur la
trésorerie de leur entreprise et je
crois que c'est important de souligner
la rapidité d'exécution
de ce fonds ces dispositifs nous devons
les renforcer donc pour tenir compte du
prolongement du confinement mais pour
tenir compte aussi des angles morts des
premiers dispositifs concernant le fonds
de solidarité nous avons écouté les
entrepreneurs et les indépendants et
nous avons apporté des améliorations qui
sont je crois attendu en premier lieu
nous avons décidé de modifier la base de
calcul de la perte du chiffre d'affaires
c'est un point qui avait été d'ailleurs
mentionné aussi par des parlementaires
de cette assemblée le mois on ne prend
plus le mois de l'année précédente comme
référence obligatoire on peut aussi
prendre une moyenne mensuelle du chiffre
d'affaires en particulier pour tenir
compte des activités qui sont heurtés en
termes de chiffre d'affaires et faire en
sorte d'avoir une approche plus juste de
la perte de chiffre d'affaires des
entrepreneurs
en deuxième lieu nous avons décidé
d'élargir le fonds aux entrepreneurs
qu'ils n'y étaient pas éligibles pour
plus de solidarité
c'est le cas des agriculteurs membres
d'un groupement agricole d'exploitation
en commun de gecc des artistes auteurs
vous savez comme moi combien la culture
est aujourd'hui impacté et des
entreprises en situation difficile
celles en redressement judiciaire et
celle en procédure de sauvegarde
nous avons enfin décidé d'augmenter le
plafond de l'envelope complémentaires
dont peuvent disposer les entreprises au
cas par cas
donc je le rappelle le dispositif se
fait en deux temps un premier temps où
les entreprises éligibles reçoivent 1500
euros et un deuxième temps où elles
peuvent présenter un complément de
dossier pour le mois de mars le
complément pourra être de 2000 euros
pour le mois d'avril cette aide
complémentaire sera portée à 5000 euros
pour tenir compte effectivement des
charges fixes de beaucoup de tpe
auxquelles elles ne peuvent faire fax le
fonds de solidarité passera en
conséquence de 1 milliard d'euros à 7
milliards d'euros
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer l'effort
des régions et leur contribution à
hauteur de 500 millions d'euros ainsi
que l'effort des assureurs qui
on annonce et abonder le fonds à hauteur
de 400 millions d'euros concernant le
soutien aux entreprises stratégiques
nous l'avons considérablement renforcée
il passera par un abondement de compte
d'affectation spécial de l'agencé des
participations de l'état à hauteur de 20
milliards d'euros via une liste
d'entreprises qui peuvent être des
entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui gérées
dans le portefeuille de la pe ça peut
être des entreprises dans lequel bpi
france et actionnaires ou des
entreprises où aucun actionnaire
en tout cas ni bpi ni ape ne figure mais
qui pour des raisons stratégiques mérite
tout notre intérêt
dernier point nous donnons les moyens de
venir en appui des hôtes et y critique
de notre pays
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce volet au tour
des entreprises en difficulté puisque
nous avons renforcé le vitesse à hauteur
de 1 milliard d'euros c'était 75
millions d'euros en fonctionnement
normal c'est le fond que nous appelons
pour organiser des situations de rebond
ou deux reprises dans tous les dossiers
d'entreprises en difficulté que nous
gérons pour renforcer les fonds propres
des entreprises de plus petite taille de
50 à 250 salariés
nous proposons également par amendement
la mise en oeuvre d'une enveloppe
d'avancés remboursables à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros nous aurons comme ça
tout une boîte à outils disponibles pour
répondre à chaque catégorie
d'entreprises en particulier
industrielles je conclurai en rappelant
effectivement l'importance de ce plan
110 milliards d'euros de dépenses
évaluées au total qui porte le niveau
d'endettement de la france à 115% le
déficit public à 9 % en 2020 c'est
endettement et des nécessaires mais
circonstances l'exigent
mais c'est aussi une un moment un peu
particulier je crois de notre histoire
économique et de notre histoire
politique
je vous remercie madame les ministres
olivier dussopt cette affaire d'état qui
sut plus particulièrement les questions
liées à la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président en quelques
mots pour sublime si le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mais monsieur le ministre sur la
question de la fonction publique nous
avons prévu dans le propos projet de loi
de finances rectificative un article qui
permettra d'exonérer de cotisation et
d'exonérer d'impôt les primes qui seront
versées aux agents publics
nous avons acté et des décrets seront
publiés prochainement pour matérialiser
et donner un fondement juridique à tout
cela le fait d'attribuer des primes aux
agents publics qui connaissent dans la
peau de confinement qui est la nôtre et
dans la crise sanitaire
nous traversons un surcroît d'activité
pour la fonction publique hospitalière
ce sont des primes qui seront financés
dans le cadre des dépenses inscrites
dans le plfss dans l'ondam gérald
darmanin rappeler que l'ondam est un
indicatif et non pas impératif nous
avons cette possibilité et les crédits
qui sont prévues à hauteur de 8
milliards d'euros permettront de
financer cela entre autres et le
président de la république et le premier
ministre l'ont dit il et soignons qui
officie partout sur le territoire
national
des ronds leurs heures supplémentaires
payées alors que généralement très
souvent en tout cas elles sont placées
sur décès étaient ou récupérer payer
majorée de 50% sur tout le territoire
par ailleurs une prime forfaitaire
exonérées de cotisations et d'impôts
sera versée aux soignants à hauteur de
1500 euros dans les départements qui
appartiennent aux 28 départements à date
qui sont considérés comme
particulièrement impactés par le virus
ou dans les 128 établissements répartis
dans les autres départements et qui ont
accueilli des malades du coronavirus il
y a évidemment des établissements dans
les départements qui ne sont pas
considérés comme particulièrement
impacté et qui n'ont pas accueilli de
malades du code vide dans ces
établissements la prime ne sera pas de
1500 euros mais de 500 euros une
discussion est ouverte avec le secteur
médico social avec les collectivités
territoriales pour faire en sorte que
les soignants des ehpad puisse
bénéficier du même type de disposition
mais la multiplicité des employeurs nous
oblige à un peu plus de temps pour
arrêter les dispositions pour la
fonction publique d'état
la prime telle qu'elle sera prévue par
décret est donc exonéré d'impôts et de
cotisations à nouveau sera une prime
plafonnée à 1000 euros
ce sont les ministères employeurs qui
décideront du périmètre d'éligibilité de
la prime en fonction du cirque de
l'activité des agents
agent en présentiel parfois de manière
certainement plus marginale agents en
télétravail et cette prime pourrait être
accordée soit à hauteur d'un tiers à 330
euros soit deux tiers ou un plafond à
1000 euros
nous estimons que environ 400 mille
agents publics de l'état
titulaires ou contractuels il n'y a pas
de différence entre les statuts seront
éligibles pour un coût total de 300
millions d'euros et ses 300 millions
d'euros peuvent être financés en gestion
puisque nous nous sommes aujourd'hui
encore en début d'année et c'est dans le
cadre du schéma de gestion avec les
différents ministères que nous
procéderons aux ajustements nécessaires
pour permettre le financement de cette
prime pour la fonction publique
territoriale les collectivités locales
pourront de manière tout à fait
volontaire dans le respect du principe
de libre administration délibéré pour
créer cette prime au sein de leur
périmètre pour leur personnel elle sera
plafonnée à 1000 euros
et ce sont les collectivités qui
décideront des agents éligibles et du
montant entre 0 et 1000 euros qui sera
accordé je précise que les agents qui
sont autorisations spéciales d'absence
ne sont pas éligibles à cette prime
puisqu'il s'agit de reconnaître à ce
surcroît d'activité
j'ajoute monsieur le président que en
plus du plfr nous avons aussi présenté
ce matin en conseil des ministres une
ordonnance sur la gestion des congés des
rtt dans la fonction publique et cette
ordonnance peut être résumée en trois
points pour les agents d'autorisations
spéciales d'absences qui sont rémunérés
à hauteur 100 % leur traitement
contrairement à chômage partiel du
secteur privé qui était plus rémunéré à
hauteur en moyenne de 84 %
les employeurs publics l'état le fera
les collectivités pourront le faire si
elle le décide
pourant des comptes et cinq jours de rtt
pour le mois qui vient de s'écouler
entre le 15 mars début du confinement et
la présentation de l'ordonance en
conseil des ministres pour la période de
confinement qui est devant nous les
collectivités où l'état pourront imposer
aux agents nasa laprise le décompte de
cinq jours de rtt ou de congés payés
pour les agents qui sont en télétravail
il n'y a pas de mesure rétroactive mais
les employeurs publics pourront imposer
si c'est nécessaire s'ils le souhaitent
cinq jours de congés ou de rtt aux
agents télétravail à condition bien
évidemment de respecter ces périodes de
congés et de ne pas
programmée du travail à distance pendant
cette période là enfin nous avons pris
un certain nombre de mesures techniques
qui visent à faire en sorte que ces
congés imposés comme dans le secteur
privé
l'heure des mois d'avril et
éventuellement mais ne soit pas
générateur de jours de fractionnement ça
serait contre-productif par rapport à
l'objectif de reprise d'activité que
nous recherchons nous avons aussi fait
en sorte de permettre et ce sera l'objet
d'un décret de basculer sur les c était
les comptes épargne temps des agents les
reliquats de congés 2019
ainsi que les congés payés générés par
les périodes d'autorisations spéciales
d'absence donc ces mesures entreront en
vigueur très vite
l'état va les appliquer aux agents de la
fonction publique d'état à l'exception
des enseignants et des personnels dont
le statut est régi différemment c'est à
dire dans le temps de travail et compter
en heures et qui ne maîtrisent
aucunement le les dates de leurs propres
congés il faut aussi préciser que la
fonction publique hospitalière n'est pas
concernée par ces dispositions et enfin
précisé que dans le cas des agents
publics dans le cas où des agents
publics pardon aurait pris des congés
pendant la période de confinement est
que ces congés n'aurait pas été annulée
par leur employeur ces congés seront
décomptées des dix jours deux plats sont
de manière à éviter ce que les
représentants de la cfdt lors des
concertations qualifiées double peine et
donc nous avons entendu et intégrer
cette disposition est enfin ces dix
jours pourront être proratisé notamment
pour les agents à temps partiel pour
ceux qui auraient les périodes d'arrêt
maladie ou encore pour tenir compte des
systèmes de roulement qui sont parfois
mises en place elles cela fait partie
des dispositions qui accompagne ce plfr
pour faciliter la gestion des ressources
humaines
l'état va le faire les collectivités
pourront le faire de la même manière
qu'elles pourront voter la prime s'ils
le souhaitent et j'ajoute pardonnez moi
cette parenthèse où ce retour en arrière
qui concernant le vote de la prime c'est
une demande quasiment unanime des
associations d'élus que de pouvoir
attribuer cette prime de manière
exceptionnelle et indépendamment du fait
qu'elle ait déployé ou non le ritz est
sûre les cadres d'emplois de leurs
effectifs
merci monsieur du soft est bien prêt
c'est trois interventions bien
coordonnée bien complémentaires bien
entendu nous allons nous tourner vers
les membres de la commission et
peut-être commencé comme il est
si on part le rapporteur général albéric
de montgolfier albéric m'entendez oui on
ne va pas bien très bien
d'abord merci pour saluer les ministres
vous remercier ma liste mais celle
ministre d'avoir bien voulu nous a
transmis des éléments en amont et bien
sûr accepté de transmettre comme nous le
souhaitions tous les éléments au fil de
l'eau concernant notamment l'exécution
du plfr un donc ça va sans doute
continuer pour le pêcheur 2 donc nous
sommes réunis pour ces deuxièmes plfr ce
qu'on avait évidemment noté lors du
premier ce que j'avais dit c'est que
d'une part les chiffres étaient
malheureusement deçà de la réalité on
l'a vérifié en avait une très bonne
piste à l'époque sur les chiffrages et
on avait dit qu'on serait amené
malheureusement à j'allais dire à se
revoir prochainement donc c était ce
sera le cas la semaine prochaine pour ce
plfr qui ajuste un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui les corrige également ma
première question porte sur le sur le
mall le macro économique puisque nous
avons également le prof de stabilité
même si ça peut paraître anecdotique en
ce moment mais c'est un document qui
reprend pour l'essentiel les discussions
du plfr 1 et du plfr 2 je voudrais vous
interrogé sur l'hypothèse de croissance
que vous avez prises puisque ce combat
remet ce que dit le fmi
la plupart des instituts de conjoncture
nous avons eu d'audit sur d'économistes
hier soir tout le monde semble tabler
sur une reprise relativement l'ombre
lente ont une sortie de confinement qui
ne seraient que progressive
or l'hypothèse que vous avez prises
semble-t-il amène à privilégier un
scénario de rebond rapide
alors j'aimerais savoir sur quels
éléments la france peut compter pour
espérer une reprise rapide
j'ai vu tout à l'heure le net un lieu de
bruno le maire qui regrettait la forte
collecte du livret a et la faible
consommation je vais dire mais je veux
bien
j'interviens ce discours mais comment en
ce moment inciter les français à
consommer alors que les commerces sont
fermés n'est pas épargné donc la
question qui se pose si le confinement
se prolonge ou signe du moins la sortie
progressive et lente est ce qu'on peut
espérer un rebond rapide
donc c'est une question qui porte tant
plutôt sur le programme de stabilité
la deuxième question mais d'autres
questions moi très rapide pas laisser la
place aux collègues elle porte sur le
plfr et notamment sur la question de la
garantie par l'état des prêts bancaires
nous avons eu une édition de ce matin du
gouverneur de la banque de france qui
est reconnu qu'il y avait à sa bande de
difficultés certaines remontent à
médiateur du crédit
certaines ne remontait pas mais des taux
de crédit tout simplement parce que les
banques ne répondait pas évidemment on
n'a pas de refus de presse formelle
certaines banques demandent des cautions
legault nous a dit ce n'est pas
normalement possible d'autres banques
demandent à ce même document qui est
difficile d'obtenir en ce moment et puis
un certain nombre d'entreprises se
trouvent exclus du dispositif par le
levier par les textes même qui prévoit
la garantie de l'état
je prends deux trois exemples des
entreprises qui sont parfois en
démarrage qui n'ont pas eu notation
suffisant de la banque de france qui
sont moins bien notés par la banque de
france une aide de 5 plus souvent refus
de prêts des entreprises qui ont pu
connaître une difficulté nous avions
évoqué avec madame est ce que l'inde est
à cette question lors du plfr 1 et c'est
vrai elle sera je le remercie en partie
résolu par le télé faire d'eux les
entreprises en difficulté les sociétés
civiles immobilières qui sont
importantes pour les commerces pour
l'hôtellerie pour les activités pour
porter des bâtiments industriels qui se
trouve également exclu évidemment il
s'agit pas de les garantir les prêts des
particuliers mais ça donc d'activités
professionnelles et de styles sont
parfois employeuse ou du moins portes de
l'immobilier professionnel et sont
exclus du dispositif
voilà est-ce que sur ces exclusions vous
avez
vous êtes conscient des limites du
dispositif est ce que le nom est très
évolués et questions complémentaires
pour quelle raison ne pas avoir une
garantie ce possible à 100% au moins
pour les pme comme le sont l'allemagne
et l'italie
j'ai encore un exemple tout à fait
concrète hütthaler tout à fait concret
thaler d'une entreprise d'une pme qui
s'est vu refuser son prêt par une grande
banque de réseau mutualiste est le
prétexte était nous avons à prendre un
risque de 10%
donc voilà donc je comprends que pour
les très grandes entreprises on puisse
avoir une limite de garantie que les
banques doivent prendre leurs quatre par
mais pourquoi la france un dispositif
qui est moins favorable que l'allemagne
de ce qu'olivier ou que l'italie est
d'ailleurs le on ne le maire du leader
quel état pourra faire des prêts directs
aux pme plutôt que de faire des prêts
directs aux pme n'est-il pas plus utile
de permettre la garantie l'état à 100%
et faire en sorte que les banques
puissent faire leur travail de prêteur
de leurs visages bien des prêts directs
par l'état de troisième question sur les
limites du fonds de solidarité
je remercie également d'avoir écouté
entendu les différentes remontées du
terrain d'avoir élargi aujourd'hui ce
que vous considérez qu'il y a des cas
qui méritera encore d'être le couvert
est ce qu'il y aura des amendements pour
élargir ce fonds de solidarité
je vais m'arrêter là juste une dernière
question peut-être budgétaire il y a
quatre milliards 2,2 crédit
j'ai bien lu le plfr qui sont annulés
sur les remboursements et dégrèvements
t4 miller de d'annulation alors qu'on
avait ouvert en pelles fr le 23 mars 4
milliards alors pourquoi ces annulations
alors qu'on venait d'avoir d'ouverture
de crédit plus importante à cet instant
et puis je ne résiste pas une dernière
question sur le chômage partiel donc lé
les chiffres ont totalement explosé on a
plus de 24 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est un effet un bon
dispositif il vaut mieux avoir à
supporter un choc temporaire un coût
très important pour l'état de chômage
partiel que d'avoir
des entreprises qu'ils soient contents
de contraintes de licencier néanmoins ne
considérons pas qu'il ya savante d'abus
je pense à des grandes entreprises
gd un exemple entreprises dans le
domaine de l'audit et du conseil où les
salariés ne subissent pas partir dans
une baisse d'activité et pour être en
télétravail ne sont pas les lieux pas
affectée par les difficultés de
fermeture des commerces ou des
fermetures et ils ont recourt
massivement au chômage partiel des
cadres en expliquant que c'est
finalement ça permet de garder de
conserver les marges
est ce que il ya pas d abus et qu'ils
soient d'amazon par exemple qui dit
qu'elle va fermer ses entrepôts en ayant
recours au chômage partiel
est ce que on peut considérer
qu'aujourd'hui le dispositif de chômage
partiel
il n'aurait pas d'abord d'abord aider
des pme
les commerces les entreprises qui sont
effectivement fermé alors que ça nombre
d'entreprises qui peuvent avoir recours
au télétravail et ne devrait pas avisé
du système
je me pose des questions manière très
directe parce que le coût est tellement
explosif c'est un bon dispositif
je pense que le gouvernement l'a très
largement ouvert en effet les publicités
ne fera pas que le coup en deviennent
insupportables
voilà merci encore une fois mesdames et
messieurs les ministres de votre écoute
et je pense que nous serons amenés nous
revoir des sur la semaine prochaine mais
à suivre de manière très directe et
concrète grâce aux documents vous nous
envoyez de manière très régulière
la consommation des ce2 les crédits qui
sont évidemment considérable merci
monsieur le rapporteur général
les ministres vont répondre à vos
questions
et puis ensuite nous allons débuter la
longue série de collègues inscrit
puisque au moment où je vous parle j'en
ai déjà une quinzaine donc j'inviterai
ceci est très bref dans leurs questions
mais également du point de vue des
réponses malheureusement il faudra
essayer d'aller assez droit au but
monsieur le
le ministre de l'action à des comptes
publics gérald darmanin pour répondre au
rappeur trr général merci monsieur
rapporteur général il ya finalement de
questions budgétaires qui me concerne
directement la première et c'est ce
dégrèvement
pourquoi 4 milliards 2 bat parce qu'en
fait assez assez logiquement elles vont
avec la baisse des prévisions d'impôt
cesser ces remboursements d'événements
qui diminue puisque il est effectivement
moins d'impôts on pense qu'il y aura
moins de dégrèvement on est prêt à le
justifier j'aurais quand même dire ou
important général mais il s'en doute
bien volontiers que la baisse des
recettes fiscales constatées dans les
prévisions évidemment et très indicatif
on a encore très peu d'éléments qui nous
permettent de les scientifiques et je
vais seulement commencé à voir les
effets sur la tva on a prévu à peu près
10 milliards de baisse de tva sur tout
cela s'aggrave at il un peu même si la
consommation notamment par l'ouverture
de la grande distribution ou du monde
agricole reste assez forte
malgré tout je comprends qu'on aura une
baisse d'impôt serait société autour de
20 milliards d'euros
parce que les marges évidemment des
entreprises vont s'amenuisent donc je
pense que ma peau société baissera
encore plus vite évidemment que la tva
on aura à peu près 4 milliards d'euros
de baisses d'impôt sur le revenu
on le constate d'abord parce qu'à une
baisse évidemment d'une manière générale
la masse salariale mais voici le fait
que les gens vont sur le dispositif de
l'impôt à la source et suppriment leur
compte ou baisse leurs taux en direct et
donc on constate d'abord l'effet de
l'impôt à la source pourrait aider les
trésoreries des ménages et des
indépendants mais aussi tout simplement
de la diminution de revenus que les
contribuables anticipe et par ailleurs
on a prévu un milliard d'euros par
exemple de baisse des icpe
on pense que ce sera sans doute plus
mais c'est très difficile évidemment à
constater maintenant et donc les
dégrèvements et remboursements suivent
ces diminutions mécanique de prévisions
de recettes sur le chômage partiel bon
ça relève évidemment d'un ministre du
travail mais vu les montants budgétaires
je me sens un peu concernés évidemment
ce chômage partiel n'est pas fait pour
permettre aux gens soient de faire
travailler les gens alors qu'ils sont au
chômage partiel c'est totalement illégal
bien sûr mais je travaille a annoncé des
contrôles soient des personnes qui
pourraient utiliser alors que leur
secteur d'activité peut continuer à
mettre une partie de leurs
collaborateurs en chômage partiel c'est
pas d'esprit du tout la disposition
votée me semble-t-il par les
parlementaires
si vous avez des exemples concrets
n'hésitez pas de les faire passer c'est
à points importants ce qui explique
d'ailleurs peut-être en partie pas
toujours mais que les directs mettre un
petit peu de temps parfois validé c'est
parce que ils peuvent avoir une
discussion sérieuse est normal avec le
chef d'entreprise évoqué le fait que ces
entreprises ne sont pas directement
concernés par les mesures de chômage
partiel
donc s'il ya des élus ils seront
évidemment sanctionnés je tiens
d'ailleurs l'attention de monsieur le
rapporteur général sur le fait que c'est
à peu près la même problématique sur les
reports de charges
nous avons eu des demandes de reports de
charges très important venant parfois de
le secteur qui n'était pas directement
impactés par la crise je pense notamment
à la banque ou la grande distribution
c'est pas le cas tous les acteurs et de
quelques-uns
voire même de deux sociétés qui
travaillent directement avec l'état dont
on connaît les marchés au contraire où
l'état est administrateur je me suis
permis d'appeler directement c'est
président aux présidentes directeurs
généraux pour leur rappeler que les
reports de charges ne sont pas des
facilités de trésorerie sont faits de
manière exceptionnelle pour payer avant
tout les fournisseurs et pour sauver les
entreprises pas pour attendre de savoir
ce qui va se passer demain
voilà donc dans tous les appels que j'ai
pu passer j'ai pu constater d'ailleurs
que le les dirigeants d'entreprise de
comprenez et ont finalement payé ses
charges
donc évidemment sa disposition qui
coûtent très chers seront trésorerie
soit en dépenses publiques tmo chômage
partiel doivent pas être abusés bien sûr
même si le temps n'est pas forcément au
contrôle sans doute faut-il limiter
effectivement ces abus je ne serai
peut-être madame là soit apte à répondre
à toutes les questions économiques merci
beaucoup sur la prévision de pub à -8%
je veux redire donc à ce stade à la
prévision du fmi est à -7 2% pour la
france italie - 9,1 en espagne - 8 la
zone euro moins 7,5 donc on est sur des
métriques qui sont assez comparables
si l'on regarde les prévisions de
croissance d'un certain nombre de deux
banques ou de consensus on tourne pour
la france pour ceux qui n'ont pas remis
à jour leur consensus donc je les écarte
mais entre -5 et moi 7 4%
donc on est quand même toujours dans les
mêmes métriques et pour répondre et
directement à votre à votre question
monsieur le rapporteur général
on est bien sur un scénario de huit
semaines de confinement et de reprise de
redémarrage progressif de l'activité
n'est pas sur un scénario de rebond sur
la question
des prêts garantis par l'état et des
points que la banque de france a
mentionné dans son gouverneur de la
banque de france a mentionné dans son
audition c'est des sujets qu'on suit de
très près j'ai moi-même réunissent de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat de
france c'est ma france cci france et la
fédération des banques ffb pour faire le
point sur le traitement des dossiers des
très petites entreprises
et effectivement poussé des schémas ou 1
il ya une automaticité sur les dossiers
qui ne font pas grief
donc c'est tout ce qui est notation de
5-plus est supérieure avec une
homogénéité des documents qui sont
demandés
effectivement je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire qu'un prévisionnel de
trésorerie à 12 mois n'a pas de sens
aujourd'hui
a fortiori s'agissant d'un commerce qui
est fermé ce point est aujourd'hui clair
entre nous et les banques
il faut prendre en compte le fait que
les banques partent d'un référentiel
classique d'instruction de dossiers et
doivent faire face à un nouveau
référentiel qui avec une garantie d'état
et avec des questions qui ne répondent
pas ce qu'elle pose celle qu'elle pose
d'habitude il est possible de demander
la notation de la banque de france
lorsqu'on n'en disposent pas il est
évidemment possible de faire appel à la
médiation du crédit est effectivement
nous notre dispositif de sécurité cnds
parce que lorsque vous êtes engagé par
une garantie d'état à 100% ça revient à
faire un crédit direct de la part de
l'état à l'entreprise
on a un système qui a fait sont la
preuve de son efficacité c'est le
vitesse est qui et qui pourraient être
utilisés sur l'ensemble du territoire je
voudrais préciser une chose sur le
dispositif de garantie à 100 % pour
l'allemagne
il est réservé aux entreprises qui sont
bénéficiaires depuis trois ans donc ça
correspond pas vraiment un dispositif
orientée vers les entreprises en
difficulté c'est peut-être la nuance
qu'il faut avoir en tête sur le fond de
solidarité
nous avons effectivement pris en compte
assez largement beaucoup de thématiques
d'élargissement la prochaine étape ce
sera clairement de faire un
un dispositif ou des dispositifs
orienter le président de la république
l'a annoncé dans son allocution de lundi
orienté sur le tourisme la culture
l'événementiel l'hôtellerie restauration
et les pistes qui sont examinées c'est
notamment un élargissement de cette
approche à des à des entreprises dont la
taille sera un peu supérieures à celles
que nous retenons aujourd'hui comme très
petites entreprises donc moins d'un
million de chiffre d'affaires moins de
10 salariés pour avoir une réponse
opérationnelle et concrète pour ces
entreprises particulières sur le chômage
partiel je voudrais juste compléter sur
un point pour avoir eu à traiter aussi
ces dossiers avec muriel qui nous bénit
qu il est clair que les demandes de
chômage partiel de grandes entreprises
sont examinés directement directement
par le cabinet de la ministre et par la
ministre elle-même qui va poser des
questions sur mais pourquoi donc 40 % de
personnes en chômage partiel à qui cela
correspond-t-il quelle est la part de
fonctions support quelle est la part de
fonction dans les boutiques et c'est
donc ce n'est pas un chèque en blanc qui
est fait aux entreprises
il faut également avoir en tête
s'agissant des entreprises qui sont dans
le domaine du conseil en réalité toutes
les prestations ont été arrêtés location
elle-même confrontée à des situations
pour une partie d'entre elles 1,2
chiffre d'affaires zéro 6 et du
commissariat aux comptes c'est plus
inquiétant parce que théoriquement c'est
un peu le moment où elles doivent sortir
les comptes et il ya un certain nombre
de d'entreprises qui en ont besoin
d'avoir de la visibilité sur leur compte
en tout état de cause comme l'a très
bien dit un monsieur le ministre il ya
des contrôles et il y aura des contrôles
merci beaucoup alors mes chers collègues
à moins que les viennois vraiment de
questions du donc nous allons débuter la
longue série de questionnements de mes
collègues on va évidemment les regrouper
parce que j'en ai maintenant seize donc
ça va être très compliqué donc ça attire
vraiment l'attention de chacun sur la
responsabilité à être concis jérôme
bascher pour commencer suivi d'éric
bouquet jérôme un oui monsieur le
président ces listes remercie les poser
une question sur les primes justement en
quoi olivier du salon parce que je
dépasse tous ont pris dans l'histoire
des 500 à 2500 euros pour les que vit
deux suivantes ont été soumis aux
mahorais 8,19 parce qu'aujourd'hui
quelques régions serre ont été commises
mais demain peut-être que toutes les
régions pays très bien sans danger pas
forcément rempli cette nuance mais
autant de cette tribu je n'ai pas
compris non plus la philosophie qui est
justifiait les passages pour le rsa
déprime ou pour les fonctionnaires
d'état à des primes ou des collectivités
locales
je pense que chacun doit prendre son
effort jugé particulier des soignants et
on comprend bien
je suis totalement d'accord que le plfr
les montants et l'esprit la philosophie
de mer général mais cette partie là
découvert un peu au débotté là
l'histoire président de la république me
laisse un peu pantois
merci merci merci jérôme éric bocquet et
puis arnaud bazin éric bocquet
oui oui on est dans tes goûts territoire
messieurs les ministres mesdames liste
alors ma question portera davantage sur
un cadre un peu plus large que celui
strictement parlant du plfr on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir en commission et
en séance la semaine prochaine dans ma
question porte davantage sur le cadre
européen et notamment le rôle de la bce
ou que la bce mon avis pourrait avoir
dans cette situation extrêmement grave
on voit bien que les cif qui sortent
depuis quelques temps sur les baisses
annoncées du pib
sont loin d'être stabilisée déficit a
explosé c'est une évidence
et est ce que la gravité de la situation
à mon avis ne poserait pas des mesures
tout à fait exceptionnelle des mesures
non conventionnelles au niveau de la bce
est-ce qu'on n'a pas raté le coche à
bruxelles la semaine dernière est-ce
qu'on n'est pas encore encore dans les
l'orthodoxie monétaire cher à nos
partenaires je pense à l'allemagne je
pense aux pays bas au luxembourg à
l'autriche par exemple et je veux mettre
en contrepoint le l'exemple de ce qui
s'est passé au royaume uni avec la
banque centrale britannique qui va
financer directement le trésor dans
cette crise afin de l'aider à affronter
les ravages sanitaires économiques
donc c'est quand même un sacré table
ronde qui vient de tomber avec les
décisions un tabou de la doxa libérale
que l'on connaît à savoir l'indépendance
des banques centrales et l'interdiction
qui leur est faite de financiers
directement des états le gouverneur de
la banque d'angleterre avait étonné ce
propos conforme à la doxa le 6 avril et
trois jours plus tard il annonce cette
décision selon laquelle la banque
d'angleterre va financer directement le
trésor britannique
la réserve fédérale américaine a pris la
décision analogue est ce qu'il ne serait
pas temps de redéfinir le rôle de la bce
dans cette crise dont on ne mesure pas
encore tout à fait à mon arrivée
aujourd'hui l'ampleur et la profondeur
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
merci merci eric arnaud bazin puis roger
karoutchi
arnaud bazin bull merci monsieur le
président madame messieurs les ministres
l'essentiel des mesures du premier plfr
disait certainement assurer le maintien
d'une trésorerie suffisante dans les
entreprises à l'exception des mesures de
chômage partiel pour celles qui ont
relevé des fonds de solidarité mais
certains secteurs d'activité sont
surtout inquiets pour leur compte
d'exploitation puisque sur leur
trésorerie et ce deuxième plfr doit
avoir à mon sens comme objectif de
resserrer le tamis de la raquette si on
ne pas perdre ainsi secteur du bâtiment
où les marges sont habituellement faible
on contre déçu roue lors de la reprise
d'activité
difficulté renchérissement
d'approvisionnement impossibilité de
venir l'aider les baisses de
productivité liés aux précautions
sanitaires en matière de marchés publics
une ordonnance apporte des réponses avec
l'intention d'en généraliser les
principaux marchés privés qui sont la
plus grande part de l'activité des
entreprises du bâtiment
d'autres petites entreprises présentent
la particularité de devoir conserver
leur main d'oeuvre avec une production
mules ou très limité il ya beaucoup
d'exemples
j'en citerai par exemple 2 sur les des
entreprises qui travaillent les animaux
les centres équestres ou les éleveurs de
chiens là il faut continuer à nourrir et
entretenir les animaux il était
commercial et arrêté largement diminué
au delà de cet exemple avec une méthode
pour recenser traiter tous les cas
particulier de l'économie réelle par
exemple aussi comme le cas des conjoints
collaborateurs oublié de tous les
dispositifs de même les entreprises
actuellement en procédure de sauvegarde
le redressement sont exclus les
empreintes trésorerie mais ne peut-on
envisager un fonds d'assistance à ces
entreprises en procédure qui pourrait en
revanche heures les frais de procédure
et leur permettre de sortir - affaibli
de cette situation enfin je voudrais
signaler on n'écarte pas un peu du sujet
une distorsion concernant les
collectivités territoriales dans le
premier train ordonnance le volet le
vote du budget primitif était possible
jusqu'au 31 juillet mais celui des
tonnelets que jusqu'au 3 juillet yatim
pas lieu de remédier à ces écarts merci
de votre attention
merci à renens roger karoutchi puis
victorin lurel roger oui monsieur le
président bonjour enfin rebonjour depuis
ce matin
madame la ministre messieurs les
ministres deux questions rapides la
première c'est concerne un peu
l'optimisme et la confiance
vous dites vous même que tous les
calculs ont été faits sur huit semaines
de confinement est ce que vous n'êtes
pas un peu trop confiants sur le fait
que au bout terme de ces huit semaines
il n'y aura plus de problème entre
guillemets liées à la crise sanitaire
entraînant des conséquences économiques
ou sociales plus lourdes d'ici la fin de
l'année
ça m'amène d'ailleurs à vous poser la
première question est ce que vous pensez
réellement comme le disent les instituts
que nous pouvons espérer une croissance
de 4 et demi pourcent 2021 et est ce que
les parts n'ira réellement vers la
consommation
et est ce que les gens ne vont pas être
tellement choqué par cette crise
évidemment il y aura plus dépendre que
de consommation la deuxième question
rapide portera sur tout le secteur de
l'hôtellerie du tourisme de la
restauration la fin du confinement ne
signifiera pas malheureusement la fin de
leurs difficultés
on a déjà appris que tout l'été était
quasiment transparent sur le plan de
l'activité pour eux il n'y aura pas
d'ouverture des frontières
il n'y aura pas de saison touristique ça
veut dire que tout ce secteur est
sinistré en réalité jusqu'à la fin de
cette année est ce que les mesures
prévues y compris celle envisagée par
jean-baptiste lemoyne seront suffisantes
pour préserver nos atouts touristiques
en france merci merci roger victor lurel
puis bernard delcros victorin hess
commentant oui on t'entend bien encore
oui parfaitement
j'ai eu des problèmes d'hier avec au
micro madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues g2c crible question sous le la
situation des entreprises françaises
notamment celles qui sont à au cac 40
avec leurs faiblesses de valorisation on
a perdu près de 40% de leur valeur
il y a des possibilités de raids
agressif ou les autres pays à très
offensive j'ai cru comprendre que vous
aviez décidé d'abonder le fonds le
compte d'affectation spéciale de 20
milliards
est ce que vous pourriez m'en dire plus
est-ce que c'est 14 milliards 2 abondant
les 5 milliards 8 qui sont aujourd'hui
disponibles 4 2 milliards en solde
cumulé et le milliard 6 pour le fonds
pour l'innovation et l'industrie s 14
milliards d'euros 20 milliards de plus
deuxième question quand deviez le f2i
est ce que c'est une mise en pause ou
une remise en cause durablement aux
remises en cause
j'aimerais être éclairé sur sa sueur
spécifiquement les outre mer 80 % des
entreprises ont moins de zéro salarié
donc elles ne sont pas éligibles au
fonds de solidarité
ensuite elles doivent être comme toutes
les autres entreprises à jour de
cotisation est ce qu'il est possible
monsieur et madame la ministre qui n'est
possible de faire ce qui avait été fait
en 2012
une circulaire de la dss de la direction
de la sécurité sociale qui permettrait
de mobiliser les créances détenues sur
les collectivités
beaucoup de collectivités territoriales
ne paye pas ratant alors la cgss refuse
d'escompté ou de mobiliser on de refuser
la cession de ces créances pour
s'acquitter de leurs charges sociales
est ce qu'on peut la craie rapidement
sur kiel six mois comme on l'avait fait
à l'époque permettre de payer ses
charges avec une mobilisation de
créances de finance commerciale ou de
créances détenues sur les collectivités
sur le chômage partiel
je pense sincèrement qu'il faut mieux
aider la nouvelle calédonie et la
polynésie française
on va garantir leurs prêts mais je pense
que la solidarité et le fait d'être
français transcende les statuts il
régime d'autonomie de l'article 74
mais je pense qu'il faut les aider
pendant quelques mois à mes coups de
poing un régime de chômage partiel ou
préserver l'emploi chez eux
en fait deux dernières choses il faut
sauver les compagnies aériennes air
france bien entendu mais toutes les
compagnies qui desservent les outre-mer
à l'arrêt et enfin on a un problème
spécifique en guadeloupe et à mayotte
c'est la distribution de l'eau on ne
peut plus se cacher derrière l'inertie
des élus depuis 40 ans il faut
aujourd'hui une intervention forte de
l'état
j'ai écrit au ministre de l'économie et
des finances ou fermier composition
notamment de subventions et de garanties
à condition de trouver la structure
comporter tout ça voilà merci
merci victorin bernard delcros et eu
l'appui didier rambaud ensuite bernard
merci des normes entendait on lit très
bien très bien madame messieurs les
ministres vous remercie de votre
présentation très très clair et très
précises et des premiers éléments de
réponse j'aurai trois questions mais je
ne serai pas long que le président la
première porte sur les reports
d'échéances fiscales et sociales qui est
une mesure évidemment importante qui
permet de répondre à l'urgence de la
situation
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative deuxième génération si je
peux dire prévoit une augmentation très
importante de l' enveloppe consacrée
cette mesure et c'est évidemment tout à
fait nécessaire mais pouvez-vous nous en
dire un peu plus sur d'éventuelles
annulations de cotisations patronales et
salariales dans un certain nombre de cas
est ce que les recours déchéance sociale
pourra se traduire par une annulation
l'envisagez-vous si oui quelles
pourraient en être les bénéficiaires et
quels seraient les critères les ma
deuxième question concerne le chômage
partiel
là aussi une enveloppe est porté à 24,2
milliards d'euros c'est tout à fait
important et essentiel pour soulager les
entreprises et maintenir à l'emploi mais
ce sauvage partiel sur quelle durée
l'envisagez-vous parce que évidemment on
les gars la situation aujourd'hui il ya
des entreprises qui vont qui reprennent
d'ailleurs déjà petit à petit le travail
d'autres qui vont le reprendre après la
première phase 2 de confinement mais on
sait aussi qu'il ya d'autres entreprises
qui ne pourront pas reprendre son
activité pendant plusieurs mois
envisagez vous de pouvoir faire perdurer
le temps nécessaire cette mesure de
chômage partiel pour préserver nos
entreprises et puis la troisième
question
mais monsieur le ministre norman et
moodie avaient en partie répondu
concernant l'impact de la contraction
des économies sur les recettes fiscales
donc vous nous avez donné une évaluation
globale concernant la tva l'impôt sur
les sociétés l'impôt sur le revenu la
tei cpe at on une évaluation aujourd'hui
où pourra-t-on faire une évaluation de
l'impact de la baisse des recettes
fiscales
cette facile concernant les
collectivités locales je parle de la
cvae
héros de la taxe de séjour et d'autres
d'autres recettes qui vont évidemment
venir impacter les collectivités locales
et puis j'avais une question très
pratique pour les entreprises sur le
fond de solidarité mais madame la
ministre vous avez répondu celles qui
ont bénéficié du 2500 euros au titre du
fonds de solidarité pourront de demander
un complément à hauteur de 5000 ou 6000
500 euros mais vous y avez répondu de
façon précise et favorablement je vous
en remercie merci bien bernard didier
rambaud didier tu l'as si vous
m'entendez
oui et puis vincent capo-canellas
ensuite en fera une pause
oui merci tout d'abord présidents vont
enfin avoir oublié cette fois ci 3 3
questions rapides
tout d'abord concernant l'impact du coût
du pétrole
je suis assez surpris que jusqu'à
présent on en parle tous or depuis le
g20 du week-end dernier on a on a acté
un double double décision à la fois la
limitation de la production de barils
par jour et aussi à un prix du baril
autour de 35 dollar
est-ce que ce l'impact de ce coût du
pétrole qui est plutôt très bas a été
intégré un peu dans nos prévisions de
croissance deuxième question concerne un
peu dans un même esprit que dans ab cros
ce record le report des charges
effectivement maintenant on parle plutôt
de d'annulation de chars moi je
considère que c'est un peu prématuré
comme question néanmoins ce qu'il est
envisagé envisageable de faire une
annulation de charge par secteur est-ce
que c'est juridiquement possible parce
que je pense que pour certaines branches
ce sera il faudra et enfin la troisième
question qui concernait les conséquence
des reports de charges pour les
collectivités locales
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit gérald en
maintenant la production que ce n'était
pas intégrée dans ce point fr néanmoins
je souhaitais faire un zoom particulier
sur une recette fiscale qui est le
versement transport
le versement mobilité qui je rappelle
est payée par les entreprises de plus
aux salariés pour les autorités de
mobilité j'étais vice président d'un
syndicat de transport
cette recette représente à minima un
tiers des recettes de des autorités de
mobilité pour la jouer
mais cela aussi en perspective merci
merci didier vincent capo-canellas ce
merci monsieur bonjour madame et
messieurs les ministres
ma question porte sur le transport
aérien le trafic aérien était réduit
très fortement de l'ordre de 98% à les
conséquences sont majeurs bien sûr
d'abord pour les compagnies aériennes et
pour tout un pan qui peut entraîner
notre économie de demain pour le
redémarrage nous savons aussi que
derrière les compagnies aériennes il ya
leurs fonctions d'achat d'achat d'avions
et donc c'est toute l'industrie
elle-même un aéronautique qui est
potentiellement risque évidemment s'il
ya moins de compagnie il ya moins
d'acheteurs et on sait que les
perspectives à moyen terme sont très
difficiles à établir il faudra aussi
demain penser à redonner confiance
essayer ensemble dirt 2 dé confiance aux
voyageurs et le milieu qui est confiné
quel avion n'est pas forcément l'endroit
vers lequel on va le plus facilement se
précipiter donc première gens sans doute
les compagnies je sais qu'il ya un
travail qui a été engagé le biz de
l'économie il a plusieurs fois fait
allusion est en cours ce matin tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre en charge
des comptes publics a évoqué d'ailleurs
les les reports de taxes qui sont
contenus dans le vent le budget annexe
dont acte c'est bien ce matin aussi
compris que les 20 milliards qui étaient
dans le compte d'affectation spéciale
soutire d'entreprise pouvaient
potentiellement être mobilisés pour ma
question c'est qu'est les calendriers
pour vous et comment vous voyez le le
soutien au secteur un secteur clé
pensons d'abord aux compagnies bien sûr
dans quel calendrier
pouvons-nous y voir clair et puis je
rejoins ce qui a été dit par victorin
orale hurel notamment on pense beaucoup
à air france mais il ya d'autres
compagnies notamment celles qui
desservent l'outre-mer il faut je crois
un plan global sa forme de gouvernement
ont déjà fait ce genre d'annoncé sur le
dire que c'est difficile
en tout cas on souhaite voilà il y voir
un peu plus clair autant vous pourrez
nous le dire a en tout cas moi sur
calendrier
deuxième point ça peut être aussi
l'occasion évidemment de faire de ce
choc terrible et chose de remise à plat
une forme de remise à plat
ce secteur-là et donc il ya peut-être
des choses à réfléchir sur la
consolidation européenne sur la taxation
sur le vide en voie de la sécurité
finalement la sécurité sanitaire et le
lien avec l'industrie de défense parce
qu'on sait tous que l'aérien porte aussi
des innovations qui sont communes avec
la défense voilà donc est ce que vous
êtes ouvert et deviennent réflexion plus
stratégique je vous remercie
chaque intervenant on aura une deuxième
série à peu près de même ampleur dans le
goût voyez que voilà les questionnements
ne manquent pas évidemment cette crise
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
tellement multiforme qui elle suscite
beaucoup de sujet de questionnement
c'est bien naturel vous avez vous est
forcé d'y répondre
j'en suis sûr messieurs milices armées
non merci monsieur le président sur la
question de monsieur bazin puisque les
premières n'étaient pas directement
adressés on va déposer un amendement
sans doute un projet de loi de finances
sur la question des déserts autour du
cirque ou des eaux aux yeux des refuges
con qu'on discute avec les ministres des
hauts en charge de ce sujet ou du mythe
à d'économie on verra quelles sont les
dispositions spécifiques
on ne connaît pas encore pour l'instant
le montant budgétaire mais effectivement
des choses effectivement que le rêve de
de cela sur les taux qui disent on
distinguait en date du vote du budget
dans l' ordonnance prise par les
ministres en charge des collectivités
locales effectivement il ya une
différence alors on a repoussé à juillet
espérons que les conseils municipaux
puissent se tenir avant
de toute manière il est possible de
tenir les ordonnances se prévoit des
conseils de municipaux dématérialisés
comme nous faisons cette commission sert
ce conseil régional se sont réunis très
récemment par ailleurs il y appartient
évidemment aux collectivités y compris
de faire voter des taux s'il le souhaite
dans ces conseils municipaux
dématérialisée on ne peut pas faire
coïncider le vote du budget
avec la date du dernier vote du budget
avec la date du vote des taux parce que
arrive à certains moments où il faut que
la production faite par la direction
générale des finances publiques qui agit
au nom des communes ou des collectivités
vous le savez bien va entraîner un
problème industriel extrêmement
important sur la façon dont les élus
vont pouvoir justement recouvrer les
impôts pour leur prochain budget donc
vraiment la date donnée par le ministère
des comptes publics ne peut pas être
amendé on le regrette
on aurait aimé mais effectivement sur
distinguer les dates mais ce n'est pas
possible on a déjà multiplié par deux le
temps qu'il faudra dg fip pour pouvoir
enfin diviser par deux le temps donné à
des défis pour pouvoir adapter toutes
les impositions évidemment très complexe
pour les 36000 communes de france
à la question de monsieur le sénateur
ministre karoutchi sur l'hôtellerie la
restauration ont rejoint d'autres sujets
autour de ce sujet moi je vais je me
concentrais sur la question des charges
et puis vendredi nous avons une réunion
avec monsieur lemoine en charge du
tourisme et monsieur misé l'économie et
des finances sur le plan de secteur sur
les aides particulières mais moi je vais
rester entre ministres des urssaf ou du
fisc sur la question des annulations de
charge plusieurs sénateurs ont posé ces
questions
bon d'accord il faut bien voir que ça ne
l'a jamais existé il n'y a jamais eu
d'annulation sectorielle de charges on
l'a fait parfois ceux des autres
territoriales pour des cas extrêmement
précis par exemple la tempe et irma fait
pour saint-martin et saint-barthélémy
lors de la crise de 2009 et des
annulations au cas par cas mais il n'y a
jamais eu d'annulation sectorielle des
charges donc il faut apprendre
disposition législative en évitant
qu'elles ne soient pas d'ailleurs
contraire au bloc de constitutionnalité
ça va poser sans doute interne des
questions juridiques m'enfin nous allons
appliquer la décision évidemment du
président de la république
le chiffre de 750 millions d'euros que
j'ai donné c'est pour l'instant les
reports de charges demandées les
annulations de charges demandé de la
part de secteurs évoqués par le
président hôtellerie restauration
hébergement événementiel à respecter
sans doute encore sans doute à modifier
ce n'est pas parce que vous n'avez pas
demandé le report de charges que vous
n'en bénéficiera que vous n'en
bénéficieraient pas donc moi je veux pas
distinguer les entreprises qu'on
demandait le report de charge puis celle
qu'ont payé leurs charges puisque 60%
des restaurants par exemple aux
demandeurs
deux chargements et même 40% des
restaurants quand même payer leurs
charges donc il faut pas qu'on distingue
sinon c'est un découragement impayés
évidemment ces charges
j'aurais bien souligner qu'il s'agit des
charges patronales pas des charges
salariales chauffe ça elles seront
payées par les salariés quand ils
reprendront le travail de chacun peut le
comprendre et nous allons donc
travailler sur ce système d'exemption
avec les professionnels pour que ce soit
à la fois législatif évidemment
constitutionnel et que ça accompagne le
plan souhaitait alors c'est tout à fait
original c'est tout à fait massif
nous ne souhaitons pas d'annulations sur
d'autres secteurs économiques
parce qu'au bout d'un moment il faut
bien comprendre mais ça je pense que
chacun de comprendre c'est que si on ne
paye plus les charges ont payé plus la
protection sociale et on est quand même
dans un système aujourd'hui où c'est pas
l'état qui touche ses charges c'est bien
les caisses et singulièrement on arrive
aujourd'hui à avoir moins de recettes
avoir plus de dépenses à payer les
prestations sociales
à l'heure même parfois avancé à payer
les retraites à l'heure à payer les
agents publics ont bien car des très
grosses tensions sur la trésorerie des
administrations publiques
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la qos et bien
incapable d'emprunter le montant je
prépare des taux d'intérêt le montant
dont elle a besoin pour payer notamment
les prestations sociales
et c'est bien là éviter l' agence france
trésor qui le fait à sa place c'est pour
montrer l'état de tension la trésorerie
chacun le comprendra donc qui dit
annulation de charge des problèmes
techniques bien sûr mais dit aussi
tensions sur la trésorerie nos
financeurs se posant la question de
savoir comment on va payer ou remboursé
on pensait tout ça pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de prêts de trésorerie de charges
pour les entreprises puisque tous est
qu'il souhaite le report l'obtiennent et
notamment les indépendants pour lequel
c'est automatique la question posée pour
sur le plan économique de relance je
passerai tata ministre l'évoquer de
manière générale ce n'est pas encore
totalement arbitrer là est la question
posée par le sénateur de noël
est très compréhensible sur les
spécificités ultramarines avant jouerait
le corriger s'il me le permet les
entreprises ultramarines ont tout à fait
le droit même avec zéro salarié davoir
le fond
4 que la ministre évoquera la question d
autres d autres étages devant les étages
régionales pourquoi on a mis des
critères sur les salariés mais ils ont
droit aux fonds indépendant à 1500 euros
nous devons quand même avoir en face de
nous des entreprises et qu'elles soient
letra marine ou peuvent être marine qui
doivent être quand même un jour de leurs
obligations fiscales et sociales
personne ne comprendrait une entreprise
confondues 3 2 fiscal par exemple
viendrait à toucher la solidarité de
l'état
ce serait bien sûr pas à pas logique
qu'est-ce qu'on a choisi de faire on a
choisi de faire de la déclaration donc
sur le site impots.gouv.fr si vous y
allez vous même grâce est extrêmement
simple un numéro de siret le nom du
dirigeant vous certifier sur l'honneur
d'avoir problème est que le fisc ou avec
le social et vous émettez votre le
rythme de votre entreprise
on l'a fait avec beaucoup d'écouté de la
part et demande entreprises qui
pourraient en difficulté si par exemple
votre directeur départemental des
finances publiques avec cette idée que
certes vous avez du retard de paiement
d'impôts mais vous êtes sur un
échéancier
on n'acceptera la demande vraiment on
est extrêmement large
voilà alors de là à dire que les
collectivités locales notamment le
travail ne paye pas les prestations des
entreprises et c'est pour cela qu'ils
paient pas leurs charges
j'entends ici ou là que ce soit possible
j'ai fait quand même assez déplacement
en outre-mer et j'essaie de remonter
pour me passionner s'ouvre sur ces
questions pour montrer qu'il ya une
partie de l'entreprise pas tout monsieur
ministres à une partie d'entre eux
risquent quand même qu'ils ne sont pas à
jour de leurs obligations sociales et
fiscales
il faut quand même dans notre pays qu'on
a que cette idée que quand on est à jour
eh ben on est plus aidé que quand on
n'est pas à jour parce que sinon quand
on paye pas ses impôts et ses
cotisations on a le bon côté la
solidarité nationale et les autres et
c'est une concurrence totalement
déloyale n'ont pas payé leurs impôts et
leurs cotisations sociales si vous avez
des cas monsieur le sénateur très
particulier où les choses peuvent
s'expliquer soit à l'ailé
des représentants de ministères dans
votre territoire peuvent évidemment il
répond nous moi même je suis à votre
disposition bien sûr mais de la règle
devrait quand même être à jour de ses
obligations fiscales et sociales ça me
paraît le minimum contre on attend la
solidarité
sur la question du pacifique la
polynésie n'a pas fait sa demande
puisque j'ai eu le président fritsch l'a
fait il ya 24 heures pour tout vous dire
de près également
moi je reste persuadé on a discuté
commises et d'outre-mer puisque peu ce
premier spa chargé de ce dossier avec
elle qu'il faut respecter et le
président se sentent a par exemple en
wallonie on est tout à fait d'accord
l'autonomie de ces gouvernements
ce qui ne veut pas dire que les prêts ne
vont pas aider à la mise en place de
dispositions sociales évoqué alors en
nouvelle calédonie il ya déjà un système
de chômage partiel en poésie n'y en a
pas du tout mais je crois que les deux
présidents deux gouvernements sur tout à
fait favorable à la façon dont le
gouvernement français les aides
indépendamment du statut que vous avez
évoqué la question a été voté lors
monsieur delcroix évoqué les charges je
perds venir seules cotisations comme le
sénateur rambo la question est évoquée
sur le report
ce pardon sont pour les collectivités
locales sur les conséquences de
fiscalité on le sait pas très bien
encore aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce que
veut dire que les collectivités locales
ont une trésorerie tout confondu de 39
milliards d'euros donc en masse ils ont
les moyens de faire face à ses
difficultés en individuel si je dirai
évidemment il ya des exceptions
nous comptons plus pour faire des
avances de fiscalité sur les deuxièmes
provisoire ou des avances de dotation de
dgf s'il le faut pour qu'elles puissent
s'ils ont vraiment après de trésorerie
il ya vraiment moins de dix cas jusqu'à
présent a porté à ma connaissance c'est
certain qu'il y aura des conséquences
fiscales je les dis pas sur leurs impôts
principaux notamment pas sur la taxe
foncière est pas sur la taxe
d'habitation et de taxe d'habitation
parce que l'état compense malgré la
crise et textes anciens parce que n'est
pas sensible pour l'instant à ces
difficultés aujourd'hui sur la tva je
rappelle que pour les régions certes sur
un problème 2021 même si un clic et met
ses antennes plus zen - un don que pour
l'instant c'est la tva de l'année
dernière donc ya pas de conséquence au
moins avant un an pour les et pour les
régions sur les impôts de production
sont payés un peu avec décalage et
retard il y aura sans doute des
difficultés mais pas immédiatement et
sur les droits de mutation sans doute ça
sera avec l'octroi de mer l'impôt le
plus sensible à la conjoncture
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir très
rapidement mais il ya toujours un mois
ou deux décalages aussi donc on a entre
guillemets
cette passivité de l'aspiration on
attend de voir exactement quelles sont
les difficultés on est en train d'y
travailler
c'est vrai que ce soit des budgets
annexes et singulièrement ce versement
transport ou les déchets il peut y avoir
des difficultés assez immédiat tige à la
fois de non versement transport par
l'entreprise ce que ça na pas production
et on peut comprendre qu'ils aient un
premier trésorerie très importante et
donc recette puisque les gens ne
prennent pas vous prête beaucoup moins
les transports en commun donc nous
regardons ça de façon extrêmement
rapprochés avec notamment france urbaine
si vous voulez vous y associer c'est
évidemment avec avec plaisir et nous
serons capables de prendre des positions
s'il le faut les versement transport et
les recettes fonkam en général faire
fonctionner à très peu de transport de
régie directe en commun il ya des
grandes sociétés aujourd'hui qui
répondent à cette délégation de service
public
je pense à transdev je pense à keolis je
n'avais pas toutes les citer mais voilà
il faut aussi qu'elles prennent leur
part l'état n'a pas de tout compenser
tout le temps ces sociétés peuvent aussi
prendre leur part de ses difficultés
donc on a un tour de table et je pense
que les représentants de la nation que
vous êtes et des collectivités locales
sont sans doute aussi sensible c'est
pareil pour les piscines par exemple que
les dégâts des services publics prennent
aussi leur part dans la difficulté que
connaît notre pays parce que par
ailleurs ils sont très aidée par l'état
série de questions qu olivier olivier
dussopt merci à monsieur le président et
pour compléter le propos du du midi
l'action des comptes publics sur les
collectivités
nous nous estimons que pour l'année 2020
ce sont entre 7 et 10% du total des
recettes des collectivités qui pourrait
être non pas supprimé mais dégradée
c'est-à-dire soit progressé moins
rapidement que prévu soit connaître une
légère érosion est l'exemple du vtt en
étant même si on doit rappeler que cette
recette est une des recettes les plus
dynamiques dans les années précédentes
puisque on avait une recette de 400
millions d'euros par an dès que les
toutes premières estimations sur le vtt
nous laisse penser que si baisse il ya
ce serait un retour aux niveaux de 2018
ce qui n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
évidemment mais reste à un niveau qui
est supérieur à ce qu'on a connu pendant
extrêmement longtemps sur ce type de
recettes
mais évidemment on le suit de très très
près comme lundi le ministre
sur la question des primes il faut bien
distinguer ce qui est présenté dans le
cadre du plfr et ce qui est permis par
ce même bfr et il y as pour schématiser
au moins trois primes qu'il faut avoir
en tête une prime que l'on qualifie de
prime sociale ou de primes pour les
ménages les plus en difficulté annoncée
par le premier ministre et les ministres
la santé et gérald darmanin disais tout
à l'heure qu'un amendement du rapporteur
général à l'assemblée pourrait affecter
une partie des 2 milliards 500 millions
d'euros de crédits non affectés dupéré
faire pour financer les presque 900
millions d'euros qui représente cette
prime qui est fixé selon ce qu'a dit le
chef du gouvernement à hauteur de 150
euros par bénéficiaire du rsa ou de la
ss plus une prime de 100 euros par
enfant pour les bénéficiaires du rsa de
la ss et des appels et il a précisé que
les titulaires de l'ue bénéficiaires de
la hache par ailleurs bénéficiaire
l'appel pourrait bénéficier de cette
prime et de cet accompagnement est pensé
pour répondre aux difficultés causées
par le confinement puisque nous savons
qu'un certain nombre de familles en
grande difficulté rencontrent des
difficultés encore plus important dans
le cadre du confinement
parce qu éloignés d'un certain nombre de
services et les sénateurs qui sont avant
tout des élus locaux savent pertinemment
que très souvent pour ne pas dire tout
le temps
les tarifs de cantine surtout lorsqu'ils
sont progressifs sont à un niveau très
bas beaucoup plus bas que le coût de
revient et plus bas souvent très souvent
que le coût de revient d'un repas
fabriqués par un conflit préparé à
domicile c'est aussi pour ça que nous
voulons aider ça c'est la première prime
la deuxième crime c'est la prime pour
les soignants cette prime pour les
soignants sera financé dans le cadre des
crédits inscrits au plfss et je le
répète
l'ondam n'étant pas un impératif mais
simplement un indicateur il ya cette
possibilité de le faire et par ailleurs
nous avons dit que 8 milliards d'euros
seraient débloqués au pti des dépenses
sociales et pour cette prime soit les
soignants pour répondre
bachère en particulier je reprécise
comment nous l'organisons d'une part il
s'agit pour tous les soignants sur la
totalité du territoire de payer des
heures supplémentaires alors
qu'habituellement
elles sont soit récupérée soit placé ans
et de t&d payer avec une majoration de
50% ce qui représente un engagement
important et nous estimons que pour un
infirmier ou une infirmière
nous sommes autour de 7 2 650 à 700
euros par mois de rémunération en plus
et bien méritée et par ailleurs nous
prévoyons une prime forfaitaire pour les
soignants et non soignants des hôpitaux
publics des établissements hospitaliers
cette prime forfaitaire sera différente
selon que l'on est dans un des
départements considéré comme un cluster
il y en a 28 à date
et si jeudi à date parce que l'évolution
de l'épidémie peut nous faire craindre
qu'à un moment ou un autre
d'autres départements entre soins a
ajouté à cette liste de départ type de
département particulièrement exposées et
nous voulons que cette prime de 1500
euros au delà des soignants et non
soignants dans les 28 départements
concernés soit aussi attribué aux
personnels des hôpitaux qui ont
accueilli des malades des malades du
coup vite sur d'autres parties du
territoire nous savons aussi que le
système hospitalier tout entier a été
mis sous tension et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans les territoires qui sont
peu ou pas exposées et dans les
établissements qui n'ont pas accueilli
de malades ducobu nous prévenir une
prime forfaitaire à 500 euros plutôt
qu'à 1500 chacun voudra la différence
d'intensité dans l'effort demandé est
enfin dernière prime pour la fonction
publique d'état à la fonction publique
territoriale
il s'agit de reconnaître un engagement
très particuliers d'agents de l'état qui
ont connu et connaissent dans cette
période un surcroît d'activité notamment
pour la mise en oeuvre des plans de
continuité d'activité qui occupent des
fonctions qui permettent la continuité
de la vie de la nation la continuité de
la vie sociale et économique et que
l'état veut récompenser accompagner je
prends un exemple mais s'agit par
exemple des enseignants qui sont portés
volontaires pour assurer la garde des
enfants des personnels soignants
ça fait partie des populations que le
ministère de l'éducation a identifiés
comme pouvant être accompagné par cette
prime notre volonté d reconnaît de les
accompagner et donc la prime d'un
montant maximal
mille euros les ministères feront le
choix de la fractionner ou pas feront le
choix de définir les périmètres en lien
avec miss à l'action des comptes publics
des agents éligibles les premiers
travaux nous avons mené avec eux laisse
penser que 400 mille agents seront
proposés pour cette prime
et nous avons estimé cette dépense à 300
millions d'euros
et enfin pour répondre à la demande des
collègues des associations de
collectivités locales nous autorisons
nous ne rendons possible pour les
collectivités le fait de voter une prime
identique plafonnait 1000 euros exonérée
de cotisations et d'impôts et les
collectivités détermineront à la fois
les montants sous plafond et les agents
éligibles avec cette même logique
d'accompagner les agents qui ont aussi
froide activités pendant cette période
pour compléter
monsieur le président donc sur
l'intervention de la banque centrale
européenne ce sont bien des mesures
exceptionnelles qui ont été prises par
la banque centrale européenne et qui
n'ont rien de conventionnel puisque avec
son programme d'achat d'actifs
pandémique
elle place la barre à 750 milliards
d'euros pour acheter de manière massive
de la dette privée et publique sur le
marché secondaire
alors il est vrai qu' une différence
avec le royaume-uni puisqu'il ne s'agit
pas d'une intervention sur le marché
primaire à l'émission mais cela a un
effet extrêmement puissant pour
améliorer les conditions de financement
des entreprises et des états voilà nous
interrompons donc cette audition
auditions de gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics des
secrétaires d'état en espagne r une
hache-- et olivier du soft qui
s'expriment actuellement devant la
commission des finances pour présenter
et bien ce nouveau budget rectifié ce
nouveau plan d'urgence 1 qui désormais
se monte à 110 milliards d'euros trois
semaines après le premier plan qui avait
été adoptée trois jours après le début
de l'épidémie et du confinement surtout
qui se montait à l'époque à 45 milliards
d'euros
notez les trois priorités notamment
détaillé par agnès panière une hache et
préservation de l'emploi soutien aux
trésoreries des entreprises soutien aux
indépendants noter également qu'olivier
d'e-sata plus précis
et les systèmes de primes annoncées par
le gouvernement prime pour la fonction
publique d'état
pour la fonction publique territoriale
mais surtout pour les soignants et une
aide exceptionnelle pour les plus
précaires notez bien que les sénateurs
vont également débattre bien sûr de ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
ça sera à la semaine prochaine mardi
dans l'hémicycle du sénat
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
me
[Musique]